whenever whenever my neighbors go on
vacation or on business to Europe or
Asia I know when they come back since
they know what I do for a living they're
going to say Joe why don't we have
high-speed rail in this country I just
went to France I just went to Germany I
just went to Japan and everyone gets
gets whisked around the country at high
speeds in a very convenient way we don't
have to deal with all the hassles of
checking in at airports and so on and so
forth why can't the u.s. do it and it's
an excellent question and in some sense
there are a variety of answers that one
could could come up with but the
simplest answer is that to date we have
been unwilling to pay at the public
within the public sector for developing
these systems the systems that I alluded
to a moment ago France Germany Japan are
all we're all initially built by the
government and the government of the
United States has chosen to make its
investments in in other areas in
highways and in air traffic control
systems and the like now why is that
certainly we have as talented a group of
transportation policy makers here in
this country is in in those other
countries one of the problems is that
from a size point of view from a
geographic point of view this is a huge
country much larger than any of the
countries that I've that I've mentioned
with 3,000 miles by 5,000 kilometers
coast to coast and 1,500 miles maybe
2,000 plus kilometers from the Canadian
border to the to the Mexican border
these are huge distances and if in fact
we would have build high-speed rail on a
national basis it's very unclear even if
we were able to do that and let me
emphasize I'm not advocating that we do
that that high-speed rail would take
much of a bite out of for example coast
to coast travel because even though
you're going at 200
something miles an hour you still got to
go 3,000 miles and it's and it's a it's
a long ride that said there are many
parts of the United States that would be
ideally suited for high-speed rail and
here we're talking about Carter's in
which the distances are in the order of
500 miles or so or less and here we have
an opportunity to compete quite actively
with with the airlines so we of course
have the Northeast Corridor the
Washington to to Boston car door and
even going further north and for the
south in which in which we have the only
system that by any definition could be
called high-speed rail and by
international standards it's really not
at all but the Northeast Corridor very
densely populated Carter would be ideal
particularly given the highway
congestion on i-95 going north and south
particularly given the congestion at the
airports in the Boston area at the three
metropolitan airports in in New York
Liberty in Newark and LaGuardia and
Kennedy and in in washington reagan
national and and Dulles these are
congested airports and one of the
reasons they congested is there's a lot
of people flying back and forth on the
corridor if we were able to attract
those people to a high quality high
speed rail system one could see
tremendous benefits from the point of
view of airline congestion airport
congestion i should say being diminished
so that's one obvious example there are
many others you could have a series of
corridors around Chicago Chicago st.
Louis Chicago Minneapolis st. Paul
Chicago Detroit and so on would be would
be ideally suited from a distance point
of view you have the Texas triangle
which is the cities of San Antonio
Dallas and Houston all of which ranked
in the top 10 population wise of this of
this country and high-speed rail zipping
people around the great state of Texas
would be would be
excellent Florida is another example
Florida we talk about a system that can
go from that would go from Tampa to
Orlando and then south to Miami and Fort
Lauderdale as again an ideally situated
example of a car that would make sense
for high-speed rail and possibly most
important and probably most most
advanced in terms of thinking is a
system for the state of California so
extending from the north and San
Francisco down to Los Angeles and down
to San Diego is is a prospect and even
further north beyond San Francisco it
could extend in principle up to Portland
and Seattle Washington and even into
into Canada into Vancouver
problem is political it's very difficult
to in fact allocate large sums of money
to one particular region of the country
and not favoring the other regions of
the country with this with the same
technology when the interstate system
was conceived and began to be built in
in the middle of the 1950s and President
Eisenhower's administration the the
notion was this would be an
interconnection system for the whole
nation for urban for rural everybody got
their piece of the action whether you
were the state of New York or whether
you were in Wyoming you were going to
get a piece of the interstate action and
get some benefit from it I don't know if
the same is viable from a high-speed
rail point of view I don't know if the
case can be made so the problem is that
we would have to invest in a relatively
small set of geographical areas in the
country to have it to have it make sense
and since in this great Republic of ours
the state of Wyoming with I don't know
half a million people has two senators
in the state of California with I don't
know 38 million people has two senators
so it's very difficult to move forward
unless the the rural states have some
benefit and one would have to work hard
to characterize this as a benefit to
them other than by an overall
improvement in economic development for
the nation at large now President Obama
is to my knowledge the first president
of the United States who's ever used the
word high-speed rail and a sentence in a
positive way something that could make
sense and in fact it's quite interesting
his comments have reverberate around the
country around the world this past
summer I was in I was in Tokyo visiting
the East Japan Railway Company with a
company I have been doing work with for
about the last 20 years and I had my
prepared talk and they say
and we hope you're going to talk about
high speed rail in the united states
since president obama is now speaking
about it and i had a very similar
experience in Portugal where we are also
doing a lot of work in in high-speed
rail when I went there to give a talk
again they said professors husband we
hope you're going to talk about the
opportunities for high-speed rail in the
United States so so this country is
still being watched as the world
scratches his head and wonders why we
don't move forward with something that
just seems to make so much sense